foreign
hey what's going on everybody we got
sound yeah okay now I'm like paranoid
every single time
yeah we're gonna um get you all ready
for the weekend it is Friday it's Easter
weekend yeah so you know and that [__]
crept up on me did it yeah I forgot all
about Easter I do too I mean we don't
really like celebrate it the only reason
I kind of remembered was because
everybody brought in salad bar at work
and nobody brought in like Cadbury Creme
eggs and stuff oh yeah there's gonna be
there's gonna be discounted [__]
Easter candy store
the day after Easter and they're gonna
discount all you have to go down there
Monday yeah get some that discounted
Easter chocolate get some of the
discounted candy yeah get all the like
Reese's peanut butter
yeah but yeah so tonight we're gonna go
to barbarellas
to Memento Mori yeah
that's tonight did we miss it last month
I think we did I think they do it twice
a month now you know that I'm thinking
about it okay but sometimes I forget
you know because I don't remember like
because it used to be easy to remember
because it was always like you know the
third Monday of the month or whatever
but I think they do it twice a month now
so now I can't remember which ones it is
and then tomorrow I have to do
like three posters okay
you gotta make money
we need money folks hopefully I can try
to find time to do something else too
but you know I don't know about y'all
but I like money
I I like money you like money too yeah
yeah I like mine
if you guys are so idiocracy you know
what we're talking about yeah I think
they're pretty you like money I can't
believe you like mine really I like
money too
yeah
picking the money uh I wanted to give a
shout out to a person named Jonathan who
sent me a tip over PayPal
earlier today oh great yeah was that the
guy that was asking about uh super um
thanks I don't know okay somebody was
asking about super thanks on that last
show we did well the last one well what
happened with I mean most of the videos
should have it I would imagine because
it's supposed to apply like across the
board yeah the last show that we did the
Gary Webb one yeah I actually didn't
monetize that one because I thought they
were probably just gonna like limit it
anyway just not not just because it's
like CIA conspiracy but also it's
because all the uh talk about the s word
you know what I mean doing away with
yourself and whatnot yeah so I was kind
of afraid they were going to demonetize
it anyway so I just said well [__] it
I'm just like not even gonna buy her how
to monetize them and make them just
demonetize it
well you know I just didn't I just oh
God it was like why bother like all of
our pretty much all of our other ones
are monetized so I'm really all that
worried about it
you know
but yeah
uh Tammy said she finished the last of
us very good we actually started
watching it we watched like the first
episode but we haven't um watched
anymore yeah it seems to be okay and we
saw the very first episode it was okay
we'll we'll watch more of it yeah there
was nothing in there that pissed me off
for oh my God I can't watch this one I
didn't realize that it was the guy from
the Mandalorian it took me a while to
realize it yeah man I know that dude I
know the dude that was the yeah it was
like why is he said yeah
yeah I don't think anybody like
mentioned that but I was like yeah
that's who that was they say the season
three of the Mandalorian just [__] is
not very good I don't know if anybody
has uh a uh password to Disney Plus
you drop us a a DM and [__] give us
that password we'll watch it we will
review it but I'm not gonna pay to see
it I don't pay Disney [__]
although I have to say they're they're
starting to do
um I think they're doing like a Hulu and
Disney bundle yeah and I already have
Hulu and I think it's only like a dollar
more or something like that because Hulu
is like eight dollars or something right
like a month and I think like for nine
something or nine yeah like you get
Disney plus as well like a bundle I
think for a dollar yeah why not you can
watch the [__] crappy Star Wars
well they
you know Mandalorian season one and two
I thought were good
three this is not that good
I heard that Obi-Wan thing wasn't very
good
um
but for a dollar I'd watch it just to
see just to see it for myself
they say the uh the Boba Fett one was
terrible
um it's just
rumor at Rumor Has It Disney's gonna
sell Star Wars they they don't think
they can salvage it we'll see Louie said
it gets better
um what gets better The Last of Us okay
I actually really liked the first
episode I think it started out really
good like started out yeah it started
out pretty good
Jeffy Hart said it seems like Pedro
Pascal is in everything these days I
wonder what Faustian deal he made
foreign
[__] might be awesome on the
casting couch yeah everybody can't tell
you he you know
he's one of them he's he's Latin you
know what I mean he's one of them he's
one of them Latin lovers [__]
jumping around somebody's [__] pole I
don't know there's no no telling there's
no telling man allegedly how these dudes
allegedly it's not alleged I made that
[__] up I just made that [__] up well
that's why you have to say allegedly
yeah
baby I don't know I don't know how these
dudes get into movies
well I I don't know either yeah I don't
know I guess they try out and sometimes
it's sus a suspect you know there's
somebody in here is pretending to be our
friend yeah what are you saying uh it's
pretending to be Jen yeah pretend to be
and saying they want you inside of them
you read it
I want you to read it to be funnier
yeah okay that's that gin okay yeah yeah
I know we know a lot of gems including
me but you know what I mean remember we
had that happen before yeah yeah it was
the same one somebody we know that it's
like that's probably [__] murder
Hornets oh yeah maybe I don't really
know
right Jen was the one that actually
reminded me that Memento Mori was
tonight because she asked if we were
going and I'm just like oh yeah well
thanks for reminding me because I would
have forgotten probably otherwise yeah
but you know
so uh so what's going on you uh what'd
you do today
um I wrote down this to uh our Starbucks
the close one here and hung out there oh
hey have you ever been to that one
before I've been to it before yeah I
never been to it yeah it's it's small
one it's just kind of chilled out it was
over there and listened to a couple
Slayer albums talk to people over
messenger
and um that's about it then came back
made pizza yeah that pizza was good yeah
it was good that's good that's that good
cheese it's a good cheese it's the good
cheese that's the good whole milk
mozzarella cheese from um
from um Sam's Club
oh okay yeah that's good that's good
I don't like that partial skim milk
[__] or the mozzarella cheese
products and then [__] that I mean it's
like passable but there really is a
noticeable difference when you use the
good [__] good cheese good [__] whole
milk mozzarella cheese stretches and it
chews almost like bubble gum that's so
you know it's the good [__] right yeah
Anthony says seeing cocaine bear or
Megan opinion we haven't seen either one
of those although I want to see both of
them actually we were actually gonna
watch Megan the other day but
um I think it was I was under the
mistaken impression that you could watch
it on what what streaming service did I
say was on but then like you ended up
having to like pay I thought it was I
thought it was one that we already had
but it wasn't and uh but yeah a lot of
people have been talking about that and
cocaine Bears must be hilarious so isn't
that one based on our true story I think
it's based on a true story Jenny's
wearing the cutest dress right now I
bought her this one
it's a little baby doll a little Gothic
baby doll that's once you stand up let
me see a dresser
it's a cute dress yeah what the [__] why
is your [__] making noise that you know
what it is it didn't turn that do not
disturb [__] selection on so people
are disturbing it yeah they're now
disturbing me
you're disturbed yeah
how do I do that I don't know
it's your [__] sorted out
Louie says cocaine bear is really good
do not disturb
I don't even know how to turn this do
not disturb thing out of my phone
I mean all I know how to do is like turn
the all the notification sound
notifications off but other than that
that's about it that's about it because
I saw that do not disturb thing and I
turned it back on off a couple days uh
today so then it started doing that
because I got a new SD card in there 256
[__] gigs
ain't that some [__]
that is some [__] [__] huge got it
for 20 bucks
that's not bad no
I was like no way
they're cheap now
and I put that in there it's a guy I can
store everything on there now
I recently had to upgrade get ready for
our only fans yeah yeah he's just
obsessed with that I got one I set one
up did you yeah they're not on it
[Laughter]
on time again
now he's trying to force me into it
like I already set it up you have to set
up you gotta do it now we already got
some [__] old video
I know but I don't know where they're at
though yeah I think they're I haven't
seen this [__] in forever I think
they're on my old no yeah it was you
abusing me of some sort of some sort no
it wasn't really that really it wasn't
really that yeah Jen was dressed up like
a Dominatrix and [__] remember that in
that [__] PVC outfit yeah this is
about 10 years ago I don't remember that
yeah we were we were [__] both real
skinny then
[Laughter]
that was fun Kaelyn said are you guys
excited for Dune part two and
Oppenheimer oh is that coming out the
good uh yeah doing part two can be good
yeah yeah yeah when is that coming out
soon I hope yeah I guess it doesn't seem
like it seemed like we just saw the the
first one but that was like a while back
they can make that [__] fast now I think
it's not like it was
slasher Fred said there was a 1970s
killer animal movie called Grizzly yeah
I've seen it
I actually saw the um I saw the regular
version and I saw the I think there's a
riftrax version
remember we watched I don't think we
watched Grizzly but we watched wasn't it
day the animals is day the Animals the
movie that has that awesome like one of
the best scenes in horror movie history
with like where that animal like picks
up that little kid in the sleeping bag
and like flings him against her Rock and
then like all the [__] stuffing goes
flying It's [__] amazing
November I think he says it comes out
yeah we'll actually have to go to the
theater and see that I think Anthony's
in there thanking me for the mozzarella
fat tip
yeah there's only two kinds of
mozzarella really you really want to use
on a pizza
whole milk
pre-shredded whole milk mozzarella if
you go to Sam's it's it's the clear bag
with the red label on it don't get the
green label that's partial skim milk
that
can be tastes like a [__] frozen
pizza all right it's just no just it's
not very good
the other one that you could use is you
go into the um
uh
the deli section and you can get cakes
of mozzarella it's a cake so it's like
that big and it's in a plastic wrapper
it's already pre-sliced usually in there
and you buy that and it's expensive you
know you're gonna probably spend about
five bucks for that thing
uh then it'll make maybe two pizza two
little pizzas or one big pizza then just
cut that out and take it out and it's
going to be pre-sliced in these discs
you can either continue you either just
use the damn discs or you can break up
the discs and spread it around or you
could shred it but that's extra time I
just would just kind of like
take the Little Slice the little disc
like slices and just break them into
like quarters and stuff and
put them over top of a pizza that's even
better than the than the uh whole milk
mozzarella shredded in there that's not
the Buffalo mozzarella yeah it's like
buff it's like Buffalo mozzarella yeah
that's cake like that big yeah it's like
a big that'll really give you yeah it's
real chewy
no chewy real good chewy and creamy no
way to describe it
yeah so I guess November the second Dune
is coming out okay
I was reading speaking of food oh wait
when that [__] comes out you can get it
in a
get the get the Blu-ray in a two pack
a collection yeah because I think I
would kind of like to watch them both
like yeah back to back because I
remember most of the [__] that happened
in the first one because I remember most
stuff in the story but I would still
want to watch the that better come in a
badass steelbook
I'm sure it will I kind of feel like a
lot of stuff should come in steel but
it's weird because
the the steelbook thing like a lot of
movies that you think are
you know should obviously ban steelbook
and they are but then there's some
movies that I think should be that
aren't and then some movies that maybe I
don't know why they are like are have
steel books you know what I'm saying
like I've seen ones like that I'm like
that's a steel book okay whatever I
guess there must have been like some
demand for it but whatever
speaking of which
um just I don't just out of the blue
Sophie sent me a link to
um yeah the clothing store kill star
yeah that does kind of you know Punk
Gothic kind of stuff they did a whole
Dario Argento inspired like clothing
line and some of that stuff is badass I
really want they I think the best one on
there they have some a lot of good [__]
but like the best thing they have on
there is
um it's kind of like a hoodie but it
sort of has like the shoulders cut out
and then it kind of has like chains and
stuff on it and then like the front of
it has the poster for um Opera his 1987
movie with like the girls eyes with the
pins like underneath yeah and it's like
it's super cool looking I think I might
need to get that I think it was only 54
which isn't bad for something like that
Super Fan trade just showed up hey
what's up yep got off work late I got
off a little bit early today
unexpectedly so that was nice I was I
was like wow I actually have time to
like get home and take a shower and redo
my makeup and all that other kind of
stuff before the show so we can go out
afterward yeah you know
murderheart said food no I was like
speaking of food I was just reading an
article just now that brought up a topic
that I actually I had never really like
thought about and it was talking about
how apparently in the food world like
everybody hates steak fries and I was
like who knew I [__] love steak fries
steak fries yeah I mean the big french
fries yeah I like the thick ones why do
they hate those I think the the most of
the reason that people hate them is
because they're like well a lot of
restaurants and stuff like that don't
cook them right and there's like they're
always too soggy right but I'm just kind
of like I don't give a [__] if they're
crispy or soggy or whatever I think
they're delicious actually like pretty
much all french fries are good
[Laughter]
I'm not picky about it in Louisiana they
take those things and they slightly
batter them in uh yeah I've seen them
done like that they're slightly battered
and then and it's got cages seasoning in
the batter and then they're deep fried
they're really good
slightly crust on them with uh Cajun
seasoning in them
good and then you
dip them [__] in blue cheese
dressing oh well I wouldn't go that far
but I mean that should work too yeah I
guess I mean I'm not a huge fan of blue
cheese dressing oh man I love it do you
know what I mean used to make it yeah
yeah at that restaurant yeah
it was uh mayonnaise sour cream a couple
seasonings he had to put in there and
then crumble a bunch of blue cheese I
think there might have been vinegar in
it too it's been a long time since I've
done it I don't know man but I really
like steak fries not quite as good like
actually my favorite are wedges like
with the skin on
but steak fries are good too
uh Danny Rowling said what's Tom and
Jenny's opinion on the film tremors 2
aftershocks do you like it or not would
you ever review it Trevor switching was
it one of the monsters under the
underground yeah yeah yeah with the
gravity well the first one had bad boy
Kevin Kevin Bacon yeah yeah uh every one
of those I saw was good did we do the
second one I know we did the I'm pretty
sure we did the first one and I think we
did the most recent one I think so yeah
the very last one okay where they ended
the series so yeah the one that came out
a couple years ago I think we reviewed
that one but I don't remember if we did
the second one or not I don't know
probably not we should probably get
around I've seen them all and I remember
them all being ranging from good to
decent yeah that's a fun Series yeah the
last one was good I yeah I really liked
it actually
uh American Military 100 Jenny did you
guys ever cover the Insidious franchise
we haven't I think I've seen them all
but I don't think you've seen them
they're actually pretty good they're not
like my favorite but
we should probably get around to that
one of these days too actually I think
xanada is gonna send us
a movie yeah he said it's probably
coming tomorrow it's Fargo yeah and I'm
super excited about it I've seen it like
I've several times it's Cohen Brothers
you know what I mean is it a western no
it's like it's a crime Thriller uh Slash
black comedy okay
um and it's great but um Tana sent me a
message and said if I send it to you
what you make time watch it oh yeah
I haven't seen it in a long time I saw
it in the theater when it came out and
then I saw it again like later on on
this but I really really like that movie
anything you guys sent us will watch it
review it I mean uh we we [__] up a
couple times during the move somebody
sent us a big stack of [__] and during
the move though those uh Blu-rays got
mixed up in the move with blue Blu-rays
or you already saw
yeah so because we had them all
separated out yeah but if if you if you
sent us anything and we didn't review it
just
DM us we'll we'll put it back on the
list yeah like um I try to remember but
it's like it's so hard
Louis Hernandez is our most uh reliable
uh fan when it comes to sending us
[__] high quality movies he's got
good taste of movies too yeah he never
sent me a bomber he'd call he calls it
man he knows my taste he said you're
gonna love this one so uh and we've done
everything and I I put the word out last
on the last shows if we've ever I said
Louie if you've ever sent me anything
and I forgot to review it you know just
tell me you know because that may have
happened and he came back to The
Breakfast Club yeah and we still need to
do breakfast club we saw it I think and
I don't think we ever reviewed it which
like I said I could probably do because
I think we went on a thing because
somebody said on um Wednesday night show
that we should do valley girl which I've
been wanting to do valley girl for a
long time because I don't think you've
ever seen that either I love valley girl
but I was like we should go off on a
whole like John Hughes yeah like 80s
movies thing like The Breakfast Club and
Pretty in Pink and some kind of
wonderful and yeah all that because
Netflix man I love all those movies I
love all those movies but um probably I
don't know it's in 16 Candles that's the
other kind of big one I think Pretty in
Pink is probably my favorite but um but
breakfast I don't know it's kind of a
tie I think between Breakfast Club yeah
I think we watched it and then got a
Weird Science and got sidetracked and
didn't do ever do the review for so
we'll have to watch it again and do the
review for it so we'll do breakfast club
in Fargo another one would be the next
one another one uh that kind of should
fit in there is Day of the Comet we
review to that one and uh night of the
comments yeah we finally got around to
doing that I love so many people like
requested it and I was like I know we'll
get around to it I swear because I
really like that movie I love that flick
I thought you might and it's kind of
like a chit an 80s chick flick that is
sci-fi Adventure post-apocalyptic and it
had good male characters and good female
characters in it and it just was a a fun
movie yeah it kind of reminded me of a
little bit of cherry 2000 yeah it's
better than Cherry too though I think a
little bit better Cherry 2000 even
though I got a soft spot for Cherry 2000
I do too but it's a little boring in
spots Meg Ryan's character is [__]
great she's real hot in it [__] she
was kind of like the female Mad Max she
had a badass [__] mustard that wasn't
Meg Ryan was it yeah it was pretty sure
it was Meg Ryan
no no she wasn't the sex bot she was the
the post-apocalyptic Hunter I think it
was Meg Ryan
uh that's right a young Meg Ryan
pretty sure
and uh she kind of played like a female
Mad Max who was going to go out into
this damn Wasteland
find the [__] chips so the client
could re reanimate the Cherry 2006 plot
that broke
that he had he was in love with it
back in the day my brother had a punk
band named after that yeah
[Laughter]
Trey said Tom will love Fargo I think he
will too
um and Louie said yeah it's the same
guys that directed The Big Lebowski yeah
yeah come on brother great flick great
flick I like that movie but um he
impressed me I was like what is this
movie about and it just it wasn't really
kind of about anything it's just about
dudes but it was it was cool and same
yeah it's like a hangout movie yeah it's
and they did um No Country for Old Men
and they did Raising Arizona and um you
know they did a lot of stuff but um
Fargo is [__] great and I haven't
seen it a long time Francis McDormand is
like fantastic in it yeah she's like a
pregnant cop it's super funny yeah yeah
that's right it wasn't Meg Ryan it was
Melanie Griffith yeah that's right
that's what I thought I was like that
doesn't sound right that's right but I
couldn't remember who it was I got the
two confused that's right
and she's she's a young Melanie in it
she's look cute as hell she had hair as
red as Jen's wig right there yes my wig
yeah yeah yeah
uh Jeffy art said hey guys it was the
movie prophecy that had the kids
sleeping bag scene that's right I knew
it was one of those 70s movies yeah
um for some reason I thought it was day
of the animals I don't know why but it's
like I can't believe they actually put
that in a movie it's like every time I
see it it's just [__] makes me laugh
she was a solid flick and it came out it
was it was it when I was it was I came
out as a little kid and my my deaf
cousin uh uh Wesley he would buy all
those fagoria fangaria magazines it's
called fangoria fangoria yeah fangoria
magazines I still love English yeah I
used to buy those I bought them all the
time and I was seeing had clips from
that and it was scaring the [__] out of
me and I saw the [__] trailer and it
scared the [__] out of me I never did
see it though until much later
and um I remember like that was the top
horror movie
for like a couple months
and then alien one came out and
everybody forgot about [__] prophecy
I'm pretty sure that that was the order
of events I think alien came out after
that
that's just that scene just like makes
me laugh every single time and I think
about it too like because whoever like
um mixes the stuff at mannequins they
have like this big long thread of like
all these little uh scenes from
different horror movies and some of them
are like pretty obscure so it's kind of
like fun to like sit there and be like
hey that's whatever hey that's Martin or
hey that's you know whatever rabid or
whatever and uh that scene is in there
just like that kid going what the hell
like it gets the Rock and it's like it
just makes me laugh every single time I
[__] see it that's in the trailer for
that movie yeah and I just saw that in
the trailer
it's so awesome because you know it's so
awesome wow Lois was taking me up from
Sequoia and Redwood forest and [__] the
cat heard some of my aunts and her
friends and Wesley and
we'd sleep outside for sleeping bags and
scare the [__] out of me that kid got
[__] away they can turn it inside out
monster bear might come and be like yeah
that's maybe that's where the um that's
where they got the idea for Jason doing
that to somebody in Friday the 13th part
seven which is still my favorite kill on
the entire Friday the 13th series
um
Larry creature says Jenny you're looking
fine this Eve thank you very much she's
looking really good she's dressed like a
girl tonight
I'm always dressed like a girl you got
that damn dress on though see she's got
great legs she always hides them but
she's got [__] great legs and she
looks good with a [__] with bare legs
well we're going out after the show so I
thought that I would yeah somebody said
something about
oh and Jeff here it said the kid looked
like a panicking yellow banana yeah
pretty much so it makes me laugh it's
making me laugh thinking about it yeah
slasher Fred said that uh Meg Ryan was
in one of the [__] Amityville horror
movies
that's right
um which one was it though was it the
third one or the fourth one I remember
like she was real young because I
remember there was a scene I must have
seen it like no she was in the
the second incesty one
that we reviewed remember that yeah I
think so the one that was kind of very
Loosely based on the defeo case it was
she'd had like a real small role she was
like a friend of of the main girl Danny
Roland Ghostface says
um Meg Ryan in the Inner Space Inner
Space yeah I remember that what is
Dennis Quaid in there enough said it's
not was she nude in it or something
yeah I kind of feel like um
I haven't seen interspace in a long time
yeah that was Dennis Quaid right
was that was that though I've never seen
it was that the one where they like
injected him like it made him really
small like injected him into somebody
else buy something like that I don't
think I've ever seen it
murderheart said Dan Franklin in one of
the Amityville one yeah I think she was
in the second one the one that was like
based and I think that was the same one
that Meg Ryan was in because we just
reviewed that one not too long ago and
like I said very very Loosely based on
the defeo murders like they changed
everybody's name and changed the time
lion and everything but Diane Franklin
was in um Better Off Dead with John
Cusack which I saw a million times when
I was remember me and my friends would
stay up late
to watch [__]
uh Friday the 13th Part Two come on
[__] one o'clock at night and we were
mostly waiting to see the scene excuse
me hot [__] blonde short-haired
counselor takes her [__] clothes off
and walks out into the [__] Lake
and when it was hot
remember what remember the scene we're
talking about kind of yeah yeah it was
only I think it was like the only time
that it was nudity in that yeah yeah
yeah I know but she was like super fit
she would look like a fitness model
look fantastic yeah Trey said Inner
Space is Dennis Quaid and it's in the
free to watch section on YouTube this
month what are these days I want to
re-watch it because I haven't seen it in
such a long time slasher Fred talking
about uh
Better Off Ted I want my two dollars I
love that movie
[Laughter]
I don't know what I said the Inner Space
was a good movie yeah I remember it
being good
I remember it being good
hot pants girl they um they weren't hot
pants she was wearing uh like they were
kind of like sweats pants they were real
tight I thought they were kind of like
Daisy Dukes no I think they were snakes
because she was like in jogging she was
in a chair outfit it was like yeah the
one that gets popped in the ass with a
slingshot that's right that's what it is
yeah you do hit her in a cheap and she
like
yeah but she had the damn little [__]
Peach cheeks coming out underneath her
[__] shorts and [__]
we were probably about 14. me and all my
friends we were still we were we were
all about it oh damn look at that
I want to touch it you know that kind of
[__] I want to touch it yeah we hadn't
touched it yet it was only like 14. a
couple years later before we were
you could just look at it on the TV they
knew exactly what they were doing man
I knew exactly what they were doing
that's what forged the male fandom of
the Friday the 13th and my generation
was [__] one and two when you're 13
or 14 years old it scared the [__] out
of you and it had naked girls in it
yeah oh [__] thank you grampers this is
spring break this is to watch Spring
Breakers and the Florida project two
spring break gems all right all right
I have been wanting to see both of those
matter of fact
and Danny Rowling says happy Easter
happy Easter to you too like I said I
forgot it was Easter until
well I couldn't really forget because
they did [__] at work today but
they oh you know what they did like a
little impromptu egg hunt and I found a
plastic egg and it had two dollars in it
I want my two dollars
so I have two dollars in cash in my
purse okay I found that two dollars but
uh but yeah
also I had a Cadbury Creme Egg which was
very good I haven't had that oh yeah
it's Easter weekend yeah I kind of feel
like um
when I was growing up we always used to
kind of do stuff for Easter you know we
always like had a ham and
we would usually go to my aunt and
uncle's house and they'd have like an
egg hunt for all the little kids and you
know had a big pot look and everything
ham macaroni salad
all that kind of stuff
I didn't really celebrate it in a long
time
you know I don't know why
it's just not I mean it's a candy based
holiday which is always a plus but
uh yeah Trey said that's why work was
nuts today
yeah I just I don't know
it I don't even know when
spring break is
I guess it's different
I always used to know because when I
lived in Daytona like I lived on the
beach side so you couldn't help but know
when spring break was because there was
people parking in front of our apartment
building and
you know falling asleep drunk and [__]
like that but um I don't know it's
always different
because different schools have it at
different times and colleges have it
like sometimes earlier sometimes later
Trey said if you recall I work at a
Walmart oh that's right yeah
okay well that explains it
tradition peer pressure from dead people
yeah
I kind of feel like that too like I do
like to celebrate stuff but I don't know
Easter is just kind of like
other than the candy I'm into that I'm
always into like candy and cake and
stuff but so anything I have to do with
that is good but
other than that I'm really not bothered
not bothered I do like I mean I love
Halloween obviously and I like Christmas
a lot too and I love Thanksgiving
because that's all about food and the
Mystery Science Theater so two of my
favorite things but other than that I
don't really like worry too much about
it
but yeah Trey said work was crazy he
works at Walmart you know because it's
Easter and everybody's like like I said
I guess it's spring break too it's
Easter you know what that mean Wednesday
when is Easter Sunday okay I'm gonna
take a damn turkey out of the freezer oh
yeah we'll have a [__] turkey dinner
we'll pretend it's like Thanksgiving
again yeah nice remember I got those
little small turkeys there froze
that's right I think I got four more
turkeys in there [__] I forgot all about
those yeah because remember like last I
think we told you guys like last
Thanksgiving like prior to Thanksgiving
like yeah turkey we're giving turkey
away yeah like Publix had turkeys like
really cheap 25 cents you could you
could only buy two though yeah but we
were going in there so it's like we
would go like one day like you would go
buy two and I would go buy two and then
we'd go back the next day and then even
so we ended up with like nine or ten of
them yeah like nine or ten times that
[__] was like [__] 25 cents a pound
yeah like like I got like a decent we
got a decent sized turkeys for like five
or six dollars for a [__] turkey that
big and we still have some of them yeah
like we made one a few months ago I was
trying to do the math and I was going
missing man that's [__] cheap you
know that's that's and I love one
quarter of the price of chicken yeah
yeah that turkey or you know
one third the price of chicken something
like that so now I got like that now I
got that to look forward to we're gonna
have Thanksgiving on Eastern
I got the scope stuffing mix so it'll
speed up the oh okay yeah I think I even
have I got frozen cranberries I'll make
some cranberry sauce with it then Matt
uh
I got
those Deluxe
um
potato flakes yeah we'll just eat that
yeah and make some turkey gravy
yeah
sounds good to me okay
granther says save the turkey next for
when family has surgery yeah
stock
oh and that's what uh the stock is when
I make gravy out of
but then I'll pull the neck out of there
and de-pone it dice it and how to put
that in gravy too
I mean might as well don't waste it
don't waste anything yeah
you can use all that [__] for the gravy
all that [__] turkey I like a liver but
a lot of people don't like it so
you take it or leave it like I don't
like a little bit's good I'll divide it
up so I have different flavors of gravy
yeah some of it have it some of it
doesn't then I have vegetable gravy too
because the stockpot got vegetables in
there and onions and uh
and a celery stick take that and I'll
hit that with an immersion blender
and then turn that into like a green
vegetable gravy it's really good yeah
that is really good I like that one
yeah
well now I'm excited that's that's way
better than ham and potato salad I can
start doing the prep tomorrow I'll take
it out tonight
sure it's on it just don't forget all
right I'll do it now
right now I'm gonna take it out right
now God damn it
well because if you wait till later
I mean you might be kind of inebriated
and then like obviously you're not gonna
remember when we come back from the club
although we're going to like I said
we're going to Barbarella and they don't
have they just have like the little like
white claw type things they don't like
have
um like liquor or liquor so I don't
usually get to
drunk there because I usually just get a
couple cans and call it a night and they
have the little water filler thing so
you can just go back by the bathrooms
and keep refilling like water so I just
usually drink water toward the end of
the night Victor says hey I made it yeah
you did
you did and it's only eight o'clock and
actually
because I got off work early I got to
come home and actually get ready to go
out before the show so I don't have to
get ready after the show so I don't have
to rush because actually we don't have
to leave until
9 30 because I don't think they open
till 10. they used to open at 9 30 but
now I think they wait until time to open
so we don't actually have to leave until
9 30.
so we still have like an hour and a half
to just kind of fart around hopefully we
don't get too like like I said I don't
want to get too [__] up before I even
go there but
well you know
but yeah like I said I'm just I'm very
excited about
having Thanksgiving dinner now for
Easter that's pretty awesome okay I'll
take the smallest one out okay I guess
how many turkeys we have total how many
turkeys five turkeys we still have five
got five turkeys yeah I was gonna say
because we made did we made two for
Thanksgiving right yeah and then I heard
another one after that yeah and I
remember you made one about a month ago
so you had eight or nine turkeys I think
we had nine of them like all together
maybe ten so I got a big freezer
downstairs in the garage
so
when good deals come up this that's
something you all need to [__] think
about if you got a house
you can go down to Sam's or something
and buy a big old [__] freezer
put that in your garage
put that in your garage that in there
and smoke it yeah
there's a bunch of different you can get
you can get a good freezer
sit down for a lay down freezer
sometimes for like 250.
you know it's like a phantom hair on my
nose
it'll store a lot
it is like yeah it's worth it in a lot
of ways yeah like and I know that people
that live in smaller places or live in
apartments like you can't really like
store a lot of stuff which kind of like
bites you in the ass and because one
good thing about like having a house is
you have a lot more room to store food
so you can buy stuff and in bulk and
like keep it you know what I mean
because we have like a whole like two
closets downstairs like full of you
could still coffee and oatmeal and all
kind of crap you could still use a lay
down freezer
in an apartment what you do is is you
put a cover over it
put it into a room like a you could even
put it in a living room if you had to so
you don't put a CV on it yeah yeah
that's true just cover it yeah you can
like it's Dual Purpose dual purpose
and then uh you know you might have
[__] seven or eight turkeys in there
and a whole bunch of [__] spiral cut
hams couple bodies you just yeah
whatever just whatever whatever comes up
on sale
you you want to punish them for that you
know what I mean like oh that's too
cheap you know we're gonna buy all that
protein even if I got to come back here
four times they will I'm going to come
back in a disguise each time and that
kind of [__] how awesome would that have
been it's like you probably don't know
they wouldn't care just go to another
[__] just you just go to another big
trench coat yeah
close and go to another check clown wig
yeah
I got one yeah like I said I don't think
they're gonna care either way but
and I think the limit is only for like a
day because like I said we went back the
next day and we both just went through
separate lines and they didn't say
anything yeah I mean it's like how are
they good what are they going to do the
next day no you're not allowed to buy
that
they're trying to get rid of the ship
yeah they had a lot yeah they were just
like so many turkeys and then after
um Thanksgiving I know excuse me no
after Halloween
there are pumpkins everywhere around
here
yeah and you can eat those well there's
a lot of pumpkin farms out here as well
and uh pumpkins yield a lot of food
and you just cut them up
bake them then scoop all that bake
material out put it in big old gallon
Ziploc bags and freeze it
yeah it's good for a year at least
and you can make all kinds of stuff
pumpkin pie
pumpkin bread pumpkin soup
Pumpkin Curry
pumpkin chicken pumpkin with chicken
curry in it that was really good yeah I
liked that a lot I had Indian spices in
it you know
oh and then we're gonna take a pumpkin
either you can make anything I call it
pumpkin pumpkin yeah that's the southern
pronunciation of pumpkin you know
well it's just easier to say yeah I call
Pookie that sometimes too pumpkin or
pudding yeah because of her little belly
[Laughter]
I had to get her some
uh uh some stuff with pumpkin in it
because
um she's having I I guess she needs more
fiber in her diet you know because she's
getting that little that little butt
thing
so I I'll see if it works I just got the
I just got it yesterday and she seems to
be eating it like I mixed it in with her
food it's supposed it's tuna flavored
and she ate some of the wet food with it
she didn't seem offended or anything so
I guess it's all right
Camp guys said we don't eat the dark
meat so there's plenty of flavor in the
carcass oh my gosh yeah yeah so Jenny
favors that [__] man yeah I'm like save
all the dark meat for me I'll eat it all
send me all the dark meat
I like the white meat too but
I don't know the dark meat's better
because it's like
it's more it's tenderer Victor Victor
Garcia says he's been meaning to get a
damn garage freezer the past three years
but yeah I don't know what state you're
in I think I think Victor might be in
California
if even if you have to order one online
just you can find good deals and have it
delivered
um no it's well worth it man you'll
you'll save you'll save a lot of money
because when you find a good deal you'll
be able to exploit it okay yeah because
it lasts a long time and then like you
know one month you're like oh we're kind
of low on money this month we don't
really have a lot of money to get
groceries but you have like a bunch of
stuff but I got a bunch of proteins
Frozen in there and you want you wanna
you want to focus on
um holiday seasons and things that are
in season the [__] will just show up and
the prices will be pretty good but then
the day after like the day after
thanksgiving's over go down there and
buy a turkey they're going to be all
yeah because they're just like just we
you know we got all these turkeys we
want to get rid of them yeah that's what
happened to us waiting for Thanksgiving
to to be over with
the very next day went to Publix those
things were [__] heavily slashed they
were just trying to get rid of yeah like
I said 25 cents a pound yeah they're
like we got like a big I got a turkey
like that size for like five years
yes indeed
so you know a lot of people get sick of
turkey though I'm like just like you
guys are high I love it when it's frozen
you know you don't have to eat it solid
you know you can that was months ago now
so you know what I mean yeah you just
put it on hold I'll get it get back to
it later it's a lot of stuff you can do
with turkey a lot of stuff you can do
with it you can even deep fry it
yeah we haven't tried that yet my
Mommy's got that huge pot my mom used to
make a kick-ass uh turkey soup
yeah she'd always make that after
Thanksgiving it was really really good
gotta have uh
peanut oil is the best
like for deep rain deep frying yeah the
the pot has to be the right size
and usually it's about a gallon of
peanut oil
that way the whole thing's submerged you
know and when the when the uh when it
gets up to temperature you have to put
a chicken inside of a duck and then put
that inside of the turkey that's your
stuff and that way there's no yeah like
a turducking interducted
that way there's no empty spot no
nothing empty inside
and then you put that in that gallon of
peanut oil
and in a huge plot I got a big old plot
and then deep fry it I've never had a
turducken either oh it comes out good
it's crispy on the outside real moist
and juicy on the inside you pull all
those birds one out of the other like a
damn Russian egg
you know what they call that thing the
Russian egg a Russian little doll yeah
Russian nesting dog Russian nesting dogs
and they're all good you put a quail
inside the chicken inside the duck
inside the turkey that's another thing
you can do
and then the very little like you put
like a little robin's egg in there yeah
yeah yeah or because it's Easter you
could put a peep except it would melt
it would just be like a little
marshmallow I like I Peeps are cute
somebody was asking me at work the other
day it was like how do you how do you
come down on the peeps issue yeah
because they said people are I said well
they're cute but I don't really like
marshmallow stuff Victor's been to
Peyton he hasn't got it because he's
been debating it against a new or used
uh you if you can fire to use when
somebody's selling one yeah go for it
but the thing is is like they got good
prices on new ones
they're not that expensive especially
you know some of the stuff that comes
from China
uh the one I got is it's not a lay down
it's a it stands up and it opens got
shelves in it and I think that was only
250.
I think I got it from Sam's
yeah Sam's has got good deals on that
kind of stuff and I said well does
Costco have um because I know Costco is
similar we have a Costco around here but
I don't know where it's at but um do
they have like appliances and [__] too
like they have like Sam says because
Sam's is like you can get computers and
refrigerators and TVs and all kind of
crap yeah and they usually have real
good prices on them yeah you just buy
one that's on sale
um the lay down ones are cheaper
you know I I think you can get something
like that probably 150. they store more
but they're kind of more of a pain in
the ass because everything's in there
stacked in there so to get into anything
yeah it's gonna take everything out
right and uh sometimes
you've been storing stuff so long it's
been iced over
so now you got to use the ice pick to
get to everything because they start to
breathe they start to frost in there
especially if the seals have kind of
gone bad around the door over time I
said I'll sometimes happen
it'll be ice icicles in there
yep have to Chip and get all his bodies
out yeah Camp guy said Costco is exactly
like Sam's except a little higher end
product lines okay yeah I've only been
in a Costco like once in my entire life
we do have them around here but we've
always had Sam's memberships because
we've always had a Sam's closer
but we do have Costco here too
yeah Camp guys at our Costco has lots of
prime grade steaks briskets Etc
yeah the Sams has that stuff too
sometimes
we used to get some good steaks there
sometimes with their meat I don't know I
kind of feel like sometimes their meat's
kind of expensive but sometimes you get
good deals on it
what time you want to shut this show
down 8 30. well we don't really have to
leave until 9 30 because they don't they
don't open till 10. okay so we got time
so we've still got time and like I said
I'm ready pretty much all I have to do
is put my shoes on
huh yeah you're ready
he's like [__] with my leg Yeah
moving me around yeah
I'm home yeah never mind you want now
I'm in a mood
I'm gonna move some of this
why are you always being like that like
so it's not bad it's so awkward I don't
know what it is
it's only a testosterone I guess so yeah
Tammy says uh I use small laundry
baskets in our chest freezer easier to
move things around and keep organized
yeah that's a good idea actually
Camp guy said you can get Prime grade
briskets for 450 to five dollars a pound
12 to 15 plus pounds so that's like at
Costco
I always kind of wondered if it was I
don't know like which one was better
like Sam's or Costco
like I said I've only been at Costco
once I don't never had a um membership
though
ours our um
um what do you call it our local Walmart
here looks like crap but they got a lot
of good [__] in there and it's cheap
they do yeah it is like kind of it looks
like [__] it really does it looks like I
don't know why they never looks like a
damn nasty ass Warehouse it just got a
raw concrete floor
uh just looks like [__] yeah but
it's kind of depressed well all Walmarts
are depressing but this one is
particularly depressing that's I try not
to go in there yeah it's ghetto as [__]
man
but it's got a lot of stuff and it's
cheap
you can get some of that malt-o Meal
cereal
yeah you know the like the generic you
get like it's like fake Captain Crunch
and [__] yeah in a big old bag and uh
the price has been Munch yeah
yeah luck mapped in Munch lucky stars
lucky smarms that shit's good though man
that's just really good the fake cereal
Malt-O-Meal fake cereal
I mean I kind of feel like depending on
what the cereal is a lot of them don't
really taste that different to the name
brands it's good for you yes well no
it's all candy Danny rolling said Life
cereal is the [__] isn't it
I like all of it I even like Mini Wheats
in front I like frosted me yeah yeah
I'll eat those just without even milk or
anything I'll just eat them right out of
the box I'll tear up [__] Raisin Bran
yeah Special okay I like Special K yeah
I'll eat [__] peanut butter Captain
Crunch I'll eat [__] Frankenberry and
blueberry okay
chocolate all you got a crappy [__] I
don't like I don't like Fruity Pebbles
either
yeah I'll eat those [__] right I'll
eat those I'll eat I'll eat any of those
[__] my favorite actually is probably
Lucky Charms
I think it's actually charms is pretty
good yeah I like my favorite guilty
pleasure I think well I love Captain
Crunch for one thing I also like Cookie
Crisp oh yeah do they still make that
man remember they had the sugar cookie
and then they had the [__] chocolate
chip cookie yeah yeah I always got the
chocolate chip cookies wait do they
still make I don't know if they still
make that or not probably not
I kind of feel like I mean there's so
many cereals now and they all have like
40 bajillion different like Flavor
variations that they didn't have when we
were kids yeah and yet they still have
never brought back waffles which were
like one of the best cereals I vaguely
remember those God those were good what
was the one honeycomb remember honeycomb
yeah I didn't quite like I didn't quite
like honeycomb there's something kind of
off about the way it tasted it was kind
of like a it's kind of like a like a
Lucky Charms but it was a different
shape and it had kind of a slight
imitation honey flavor that didn't quite
work for me
what was the one about what's called
monster tree or something called monster
tree cereal
monster tree yeah it came with toys in
there it looked like a little car
[__] I think it was called monster
tree they had like four or five
different kind of monsters that came out
of the damn tree I think it was called
monster tree
this is gimmick cereal when I was a
little kid 70s I don't think it was
called creature tree or monster tree I
don't remember that
and all the little monsters looked like
they were in roots or something out of
out of a plant
that's weird
so you might remember better than I do
you sure that wasn't just a fever dream
that you had oh no I have my I mean they
did make some weird-ass series maybe I
just never bought it it was California
and maybe yeah oh yeah maybe they didn't
sell it here they had [__] in California
Google [__]
cocoa peanut butter
remember that no it was it came in a jar
and it had four or five different
flavors
and um cougar was would be like uh
chocolate and cinnamon
peanut butter
uh [__] peanut butter as strawberry
peanut butter even though it wasn't
jelly it was
strawberry favorite peanut butter
[__] it was bizarre it was like a
peanut butter pretty weird it was a
peanut butter like spread
some of it was
and they might have been called it was
called Google let me see if I can find
or kookly eyes or google eyes Maybe
Danny Rowling said if I gave you money
would you be able to make a 2005 House
of Wax film inspired screen printed
hoodie uh yeah yeah yeah we could do
that
we could do that
uh Victor said start it on test
oh yeah trt and Victor Garcia okay yeah
yeah it started TRC in February my test
levels have gone from 138 to 1200. oh
good twelve hundred yes indeed haven't
hit the gym yet but just hired a trainer
yeah with him next week how old are you
and uh you feel feel better don't you
how long you been on it well you said
since February February so about four or
five months no that's only like two
months two months okay yeah all right I
don't remember what month it was it's
only it's only April okay so he should
be in the February in the thick of the
pond far right about now
after about two months are you trying to
[__] everything
the pond the pond far yeah your second
puberty
said I bought the six pack of giant
commercial grade toilet paper rolls to
use as a last resort if my regular paper
runs out yeah we have like um like three
cases of the [__] like in the garage
I just stacked on top of the area
Google oh I kind of remember that cool I
don't know if they sold it here though
we never bought it and it has eyes on it
yeah Google like googly eyes yeah I get
it
that's crazy let's see if I can show
them poodle peanut butter spread yeah
yeah yeah
it's weird I remember that [__] when I
was that was from the 70s cinnamon
peanuts bread yeah yeah that sounds kind
of good yeah banana can suck a dick
though I loved it as a kid and
everything and my mom would try it and
every adult that tried it would go oh
it's terrible so it was something that
only kids liked I guess banana what's it
say banana peanut spread
yeah vanilla peanut spray okay that
might be chocolate peanut spread
cinnamon peanut spread yeah good
Victor says he's 41. okay definitely
feeling more energetic that's a good
time to go on had I known I'd have gone
on at that age
go on there I don't know where you're
getting it if you're getting that from
an HRT Clinic
you can DM me later just run with them
for
six months or so
and then there are other ways to get it
other other you can get it online
do that
bag it up later on bang it up to like
250 milligrams
and then run it like that for a little
while then sometimes you can go up to
like 500 milligrams a week and do some
NPP natural lung phenopropionate [__]
short Ester nandler alone man that
shit's good
um and you'll
just repair up you'll just heal up
you'll you but the thing is is you don't
want to do any of that kind of stuff
until you're lifting you know that way
you make use of it the body will know
what to do with it
but you know just stay in contact with
me as you develop you got a trainer
you can check up with me out you know if
your trainer's telling you the right
thing Traders should be telling you to
eat a lot of protein stay away from
carbohydrates lift a lot
grandpa said if Tom had Mr Schulte your
English class he has gone on to the big
high school in the sky I just saw that I
don't know the guy I don't remember him
I don't think I had him
Jeffy Hart said my mom used to buy kicks
in bulk when we wanted to make Christmas
decorations kicks yeah I remember yeah
it made better Christmas decoration than
a cereal anyway
yeah I remember those being not very
good there was something that we used to
make
you took Chex cereal
peanut butter no peanuts
little um let me call them pretzels
pretzels yeah chex mix chex mix right
and then you you'd put put
Worcestershire sauce yeah yeah that's
Chex Mix oh is that what it's called
yeah toss it man that [__] was good yeah
it's on the back of the damn box yeah
everybody makes that man that [__] was
good yeah Chex Mix I think they even
Chex Mix was so popular like just making
it that now they started selling well
now they just sell it like in a bag like
already made yeah she was good man
laughs
it's pretty good you can even get it in
different flavors and stuff now I think
it was kind of addictive
yeah you'd go that can't that that's not
gonna be good you try it you go oh no
that's just looking good and you can't
walk away from it you gotta go back over
there and get some water I think you had
peanuts in it maybe it did
I mean there um there is a version that
you can put peanuts in well you can put
pretty much anything yeah I think we
think we put croutons in it too
yeah fair enough yeah you could put a
croutons in there you can put whatever
you want in there yeah
but I can't remember what like what's in
the classic Chex Mix is I think Chex
pretzels uh Worcestershire sauce maybe
Tabasco
um I don't know about Tabasco but and
then I think there was like something
it's like nuts or something like that
yeah something it was good been a long
time since I made it yeah everybody like
I kind of feel like everybody made that
for parties and stuff like in the 70s no
it haven't made a long time it's a damn
eclair's in the cookbook yeah you have
it you may have to make some eclairs
again
you say that but then you never know
they're labor intensive I know the
recipes in the cookbook that we sell
they're and we got that recipe out of a
Duncan Hines
cookbook from the very late 30s or the
early 40s I don't remember yeah I got
the cookbook down there it's falling
apart it's been in the family for
[__] Generations
that cookbook is the [__]
and tell you how to Salt meat
tells you how to make mayonnaise tells
you how to make
um ingredients for things we'll make
everything from scratch well because you
had to you had to back then back then
and then it would tell you how to make
prepared mustard [__] like that
um
but the the most impressive most of the
shit's kind of backwards
like they had a foreign food section and
it had spaghetti and meatballs yeah and
the recipe for the [__] sauce is
terrible
because that's the way they made it back
then it has to explain to you what
oregano is
because they didn't know what oregano
was back then
they weren't quite sure what Italian was
either what Italian food was seriously
if you ever watch that series like the
food that built America the food that
made America or whatever there's a
episode about Chef Boyardee who is a
real guy and how he like sort of helped
to introduce like Italian food to Middle
America pretty much because it seems
crazy now but like there was a time not
that long ago when Italian food was like
seen as some weird exotic yeah
they didn't know what it was they're
just like hilarious in that old Duncan
Hines book though
the best thing about it is the uh the
dessert and pastry sections how to make
the cakes and the cookies
and the bread man everything in there is
[__] great it teaches you how to make
cake frosting
how to make butter
and then take that butter and turn it in
a cake frosting and their recipes are
[__] fantastic
everything's made with [__]
milk cream eggs
butter
uh they'd use shortening
they they mentioned like Tallow or you
know just beef [__] drippings uh they
just they tell you how to make things
make things you might need later on how
to preserve Meats
it's looking really good cookbook and
some of it
a few of those recipes are in the
cookbook that we sell
but uh
some of the best cookie recipes you've
ever imagined peanut butter cookies
uh they had all the cookies you brought
they actually had a recipe for
snickerdoodles in there
snickerdoodles have been around for a
long time they're real good and I like
Snickers sugar cookies
um
cinnamon sugar cookies they had that
fruitcake they teach you how to make
that and the fruitcakes got rum in it
well yeah that's the best kind yeah if
you're gonna make fruitcake you might as
well put booze in there yeah
that makes everything better
granther says Americans ate boring [__]
back in the day true yeah I was just
because there was no Supply I was raised
on meatloaf and pork chops yeah never
anything interesting or unique yeah I
mean me pretty much the same our
grandparents Generations only ate
basically local what was available
locally
because its Supply was spotty and they
lived through the Great Depression
so they were paranoid about getting sick
so they overcooked everything especially
vegetables they just boiled spinach to
death I know I told you I thought I
hated vegetables for the longest time
they boiled vegetables until they were
just slime
because they were scared of dying
because I think they were growing those
vegetables in the backyard using their
own feces Maybe
it's like well it was the depression so
I think I'd be boiling food if like I
knew somebody pooped all over it too
well you know in Mississippi they had
outhouses so that's probably where they
were getting the fertilizer yeah out of
the outhouse
during that era you know of the Great
Depression
my grandmother said
that she grew up
chew and tar tar that came off of the
roads
because it because uh they didn't have
bubble gum so they would just go in the
summer in Mississippi pull up the edge
of the road and chew it why would that
even occur to you they pretended it was
gum
the depression is over I guess
they she grew up there in the depression
here let me pick this bit off the road
and eat it yeah what the [__] is that
all about that poverty that literally
would never occur to me yeah I don't
need golly it was chewy it was chewy I
know but it's like I don't need gum that
bad Jesus
but yeah I kind of feel like when I was
growing up we yeah we ate a lot of um
meatloaf pork chops
chicken and dumplings that was good
though I like that
you know uh a lot of those kind of
Stouffers
things in the oven you know what I mean
like the things that were like the
sliced turkey and kind of like TV
dinners we ate a lot of those
yeah Ian England says quick question I
was given about a 10 ounce smoked
venison loin today yeah any
recommendations on how long and hot to
cook it for uh no you'd have to you'd
have to look because
if it's smoked it should be ready to eat
the smoking process you could eat it
like makes it just
grandpar said I've read they use human
waste for fertilizer in North Korea and
tapeworm yeah is a huge problem there
but yeah they all got tape worse yeah I
mean all the all the regular people the
rich people in Pyongyang probably don't
Danny Rowling said Tom should add a
recipe for Vietnamese sweet and sour cow
vagina why would I want to do this a
Vietnam street food delicacy
some things that like people eat I like
I know there's always a history behind
stuff it's like why would anybody like
put that voluntarily in their mouth
you know what I mean yeah he was the
first person
to be like you know what I could eat
that and then other people like follow I
don't I don't get it I don't get it well
like I said he was the first person that
like picked some [__] off the side of
the road and said hey it's like gum
let's see like who was the first person
to do that depression kids I know but
it's like why on Earth would you [__]
you also smoked well that well yeah but
that's like more understandable I feel
like my grandmother started smoking at
like seven
that's a weird [__]
seven-year-old kid like seven years the
good old days
[Laughter]
and then like later on when they got old
they like sit there and like freaked out
about you know
people [__] drinking and [__] like
that or uh well some did some did
teenagers doing just regular teenager
[__] I think like you were smoking you
were seven Grandma shut up then it
depended on
where you were
in the in the country and what your
socioeconomic class was at the time
and because
in Mississippi
the real Bible Thumpers were not my
grandmother's generation they were my
dad's generation
and they they were a lot more middle
class
our grandmother's generation in
Mississippi where they were basically
subsistence Farmers they had jobs she
had a job when she got older she were
worked in a department store but they
also farmed in the back behind the house
they had probably about an acre or two
they'd have corn out there and tomatoes
and [__] watermelons and
and they ate off of that
they weren't prudish they were tough
most of them were married and pregnant
by 14.
so it was not
and they weren't that religious they
were too poor to be religious
you know what I mean
you couldn't you don't think you could
follow any of that [__]
yeah you know you couldn't they were
they were too poor
um and they uh
they bootlegged and stuff
they also got in fights and killed each
other it was just you know it was the
Hatfield McCoy type stuff it was an
anarchy there weren't
there weren't there wasn't really law
enforcement
they weren't you know a cops would come
and try to sort things out afterwards
but it was usually just like all right
y'all stop stop shooting you know it's
that kind of [__] you know what I mean
they y'all shoot knock it off they all
grew up together they all knew ever you
know they weren't gonna [__] send
anybody to prison oh [__] he got hit
look just move him over there all right
move him over there and give him a nice
Barrel y'all knock it off don't make me
come back out here
they didn't give a [__]
Danny Rowling said what's Wednesday's
show going to be I don't know yet
because uh the poll does not end till
Sunday afternoon
like Sunday at noon Eastern Standard
Time Jeffy art said with six mounts to
feed eight if you're counting the dogs
uh my mom made baking chicken and
casseroles and art until we became
teenagers then she said [__] it I'm
ordering pizzas yeah you know I can't
say a blamer casser rolls are great I
mean especially if you're like feeding
the big because you can do a lot of [__]
with them yeah you can do a lot of [__]
with him and they're good for um
leftovers because you can kind of throw
it into anything like that like quiches
or anything like that that you can just
kind of throw everything in there like
yeah making big
kind of egg dishes when throwing all the
leftover meat and veggies in there my
Mississippi Grandma hurt
as far as I know her name was little
mama as far as I know okay you know you
don't know what her real name is her
real name was Catherine
all southern women are named cat or
Catherine her name is Catherine her name
is Catherine Womack that was her real
she didn't have Ross she married she
married after she remarried after my
granddad died and married a guy named
with the last name Womack so she her
name is Catherine Womack
and uh
she was a by the time the 70s and 60s
and 70s rolled around which you know she
was already old by then
she was a master of the casserole I got
some of that before she died casserole
casserole she was casserole Queen man
did cook
two big old
they cook more than they could eat you
know [__] funny they had two big old
glass pans of casseroles and it'd be
like spaghetti
in uh Velveeta cheese and milk to make
like a like like spaghetti with uh
macaroni you know spaghetti with like
American cheese on it right with just
like you said diced up pieces of chicken
or bacon in it with bacon drippings or
how about some cut up hot dogs no no
if they were gonna do something like cut
of hot dogs they just use Vienna sausage
that's true yeah because uh hot dogs you
can make a real hot dog with that so
yeah but don't know they they no they
had food man the food was great
and then they'd pour Rotel in it can a
Rotel and mix it up so it had tomatoes
and green peppers in it and maybe like a
little bit of Cajun Tony sassory's Cajun
seasoning in it
and then they the chicken and then they
top it off with bread crumbs that were
soaked in melted butter and put that on
top of it and then bake it so it would
have a crust on the top of it
man you talking good that sounds pretty
good actually good it might have a can
of green peas in it
man that [__] was [__] all carbs yeah
you just throw all the [__] in this
condition and like use feed everybody
with it that's why Southerners were so
[__] fat and they all [__] died of
heart attacks yeah they died happy man
they're well
that's true yeah
they all they all had the diabetes yeah
that's the same way you know Mexican's
exactly the same way you know if I could
just asking about Mexican food delicious
they're gonna sit there they don't care
if it's healthy it's just gonna better
be good it better be good have a lot of
carbs a lot of fat in it it better give
you diabetes if you're not getting
diabetes that food's not good you're
doing it wrong yeah
[Laughter]
Southerners are the Mexicans of America
of anglo-america We're the Mexicans yeah
we do that same [__] Danny rolling said
little short fat people said tuna
casserole is the [__] yeah yeah
like I said I can I can doubt a good
casserole tuna noodle casserole real
good the cream sauce in there and peas
and got that same crumble crust oh yeah
we made that like not too long ago yeah
it's good Danny Rowling said making
chili and then topping it with Jiffy
cornbread mix and serving it as a
casserole yeah yeah and then you call
the [__] like something like Mexican
cornbread or Texas cornbread or
something like that we made a couple
casseroles like that we're not I guess
it was kind of with chili but then they
had like the cornbread crust on top with
like other yeah and speaking of Rotel
all good about for that Rotel and
Velveeta dip yeah yeah that everybody
makes another another one that my
Mexican friends will be proud of this
another one my grandmother made that she
would make [__] pans of uh of tamales
yummy yeah it had
basically like a like a cornbread on the
bottom and then the meat and then more
of the tamale cornbread on the top so
you know how to make it out of cornmeal
or it was like like a Masa made out of
cornmeal and then bake it like that and
then she uh and it would come out like a
tamale and you just cut it in squares it
wasn't any didn't have any corn husks as
a wrapper or anything
that [__] was good man really good
she knew how to make that
um because it was just so easy to make
it that way you're not sitting around
wrapping them up
you know yeah and steaming them
although now we're trying to make an old
pan of tamales now they're talking about
casseroles and stuff like that now I'm
kind of like I kind of actually called
it tamale casserole yeah yeah yeah I was
kind of thinking like we haven't had
quiche in a while I can make quiche it's
heavy and cheese but I got I got cheese
you want to use a good uh a good cheddar
and I'll I'll just grate it
it's very gotta buy more eggs there's a
lot of eggs a lot of cream in that
that's true I got the cream though
I mean when I was like a quiche lorrade
when you were at bike night on Tuesday
and I went down to the Publix Deli to
see what they had like because I went
down and got something to eat and they
had they had that little um two pieces
of quiche yeah that you can get for like
you know four or five dollars and I was
I was gonna get that but I didn't I
ended up just getting the salad and
sandwich instead but
but the quiche is uh is good their
quiche is actually good see when Keys
first showed up man a lot of dudes
wouldn't need it they'd say that that
only gay men ate quiche
read that Santa
so
for all y'all to think that [__]
eating quiche makes you gay
it makes him gay
but it doesn't matter because it's you
need that you're gonna be gay well hey
like if people are still worth it though
maybe people think that then I'd be like
okay more quiche for me then
anybody think does anybody think that
anymore
wasn't that a book real men don't eat
kids
that was like a it was like a cultural
thing yeah well it was just I feel like
that was kind of like the
you know what maybe like a few years ago
when everybody was whining about kale
and avocado toast and [__] like that
it's the same kind of [__] like people
are always whining about these kids
today they're so [__] and they're just
like Danny says it that's so dumb Danny
says ranch dressing will make you gay I
don't doubt it I don't doubt it so
that's so the entire Midwest is gay
though
I didn't like okay secret to the gay
game the game the secret to the gay game
of chicken is to just go yeah yeah yeah
are you gay yeah then they got nothing
on you see well yeah because the whole
reason like people get uh like tell you
like that is they're trying to [__] with
you they're trying to get you to go away
okay so if it doesn't bother you then
yeah you're taking all the wind out
there unless unless unless you're
[__] with uh Victor says Lucky Charms
made me gay yeah look yeah definitely
well it's a little Shamrocks yeah well
it's the whole rainbow the diamonds and
[__] yeah and weren't they horseshoes
purple horses I don't think so yeah
there's purple horseshoes right I'm
trying to remember gay and Irish makes
you gay and Irish simultaneously and a
leprechaun
that's what happened to me man I was
eating all that damn Lucky Charms man
it's like it made you gay and short gay
is short see don't fight it don't fight
it just don't get it
eat that [__] and just started sucking
dicks just see his dick just flying
flying at me there's nothing I can do
about it couldn't resist couldn't resist
you about it yeah
yeah so they're trying to play chicken
with you there's only a there's only
like one guy that I know of that [__]
you can't play chicken with and that's
for you know oh doctor uh what's his
name Dr Michael Dr Michael tonight he'll
be at the club tonight oh you think I'm
pretty sure he usually goes out
Saturdays but oh he does okay yeah but
he might I don't know he might be there
I'm not sure Dr Michael's this like a
vet that we know he's got he shows up
the club and he looks like Riff Raff
he looks like Riff Raff for [__]
Rocky Horror
[__] bald but he's got real long
sides that go all the way down and he's
looking kind of skinny fat and uh
where's [__] long stockings on his
hands and shorts and black combat boots
with [__] long socks that go up to
his [__] knees and some kind of goth
t-shirt and a big old belly out there
like that and [__] he's got this goofy
ass grin with his teeth all spaced out
and [__] but he's funny as [__] funny as
[__] and
yeah
he comes at you doing all this [__]
[__] you know he's just kind of one of
these pad sexual dudes you know what I
mean look at he'll go after women or
dudes or whatever just but he's so funny
you know he's friends with everybody
we've known him for a long time
he just likes to just [__] with
everybody and
um
I said something the other day and I
said
we should have gotten to an argument
and I suppose so you come over here to
suck my [__] dick then he [__] ran
straight at him [__] landed on his
knees
he's trying to [__] get my pants he's
away he's like what what I tell you what
hold on hold on man hold on dude you
said it yeah
I was [__] with you
don't tease a man like that yeah yeah
yeah you can't play chicken with him
yeah well he'll absolutely do it he'll
do it yeah he'll do if you're [__]
around he'll just be like okay
Danny Rowling said pink Snowballs will
do it as well yeah oh yeah it was
definitely turning again I don't like
those yeah they got the stretch to him
you bite him to stretched remember that
and they had the little pink [__] is
there a marshmallow in there yeah it is
pink see that's why pink coconut over
white marshmallow over a chocolate
cake with a little bit of cream filling
in there
the thing about marshmallow I just don't
like it well I mean that's neither here
nor there but the thing I don't like
about it is sometimes like you'll see a
thing and it'll be like oh it's a candy
bar and it's like take a bite out of it
and I'm expecting like you know I'm
especially like a little bit of crunch a
little bit of texture a little bit and
then it just goes I don't know like
because it's just marshmallow and I'm
like gross
it's just so blah
Jeffy art said I've been gay since 12
and I didn't eat keesh until I was 19.
coming from a German family I think it
was eating all the holiday sausages
casseroles that made me gay yeah yeah
the sausages did it because yeah you're
always kind of like the other thing is
is that some of that food that you've
eaten is so gay that it can
retroactively make you gay it can reach
back
and make you gay as a child that's how
that's how gay some of that [__] is see
because you ate it later it made you gay
as a child okay so so back in time
what's the taxonomy Back to the Future
what's the taxonomy of gayness on
sausages because you would think that
they would be the gayest food ever or
the manliest food ever or does it just
need it also over there that's what I'm
saying it's like male Supreme does it
kind of go around in a circle and just
kind of like meet right up there you
could just be such a superior male that
it's all just about men and manly men
with other manly men doing manly manly
things it went women don't even exist
okay there there isn't even any
femininity at that level okay there's no
choice they're not gay because there's
no other choice you know what I mean
they're they're there are no women at
that level
just man
if you said well why are you guys having
sex with men they go well what's that
this is we're not supposed to be women
like what's that it's just what are
women there's yeah what are women
what's a man what are these inferior
creatures you speak of the male
Supremacy level is so high there's no
other choice
it's just merged all the men have merged
together into one big [__] into
one big man one big man
rubbing and loving on one anymore oh
Tom's fantasy he's getting all excited
it's not a fantasy it's just a fact it's
just a fact I'm just describing
something that's real okay
you think about this way more than I do
you asked me you asked me you asked me
no I asked you about sausages yes that's
where they come from specifically
they're in there [__] sausages are
flying out oh that's right where's
[__] not worse dude I'm not that's
not even a real German sauce they got
all kinds of Germans lots of worst yeah
all kind of German sausages coming out
sausage and sausage out
in and out and in and out sausages it's
a sausage party yeah
can you blame them
who the sausages just those
this is why he doesn't want to hang out
with women anymore
Jeff yarn says Tom is teaching gay
quantum physics and Rainbow string
theory thank you thank you thank you
you should you should teach a class I
just did
just did man it's like an einsteinian
[__] thing man
you know just Einstein would just
imagine [__] relativity first he saw
I imagined it in his head it was all
true that's just what I just did right
there he's playing the entire gay
continuum
and how meat is made
[Laughter]
every gay dude in there knows exactly
they accepted this as a truth
you know Jeffy or one big giant super
sausage yeah
choice they don't have a choice
too [__] manly man
what are you gonna do right what are you
gonna do there is no other choice
there's no other choice when you're that
[__] Macho there it is
you've just arrived at that you know I
arrived at machinist all that gayness
yeah
Macho Macho exactly you know I didn't
think those dudes are too Macho but
whatever
I actually like saying though yeah they
could dance I actually heard YMCA at
work today
that was good Disco
I'm kind of I I kind of like disco yeah
yeah it's good it's a good disco yeah
there's a lot of bad disco well yeah
well there's a lot of bad of everything
you know what I mean because the soonest
like somebody good comes along and does
some good [__] then there'll be like 40
people like ripping that off it's like
the best was the BG's I heard some Bee
Gees today yeah it's kind of hard to
beat the BG's when it comes I really do
like the PJs actually not like not even
ironically what fantastic lyrics yeah
those are female fantasy lyrics all
right that's what a woman is thinking
that's what a woman wants you to tell
her I don't know who wrote those lyrics
man but he understood female psychology
probably a woman wrote that
and then he took credit for it yeah
that figures probably
Danny Rowling said a recipe for Death
Proof style nachos would be sick to add
to your cookbook
uh Jeffy art says the universe is
destined to collapse into itself and one
big Pride event yeah
yeah
Daniel Rowling said beer brats and spicy
Italian sausage are the best sausages I
mean all sausages are good except blood
sausage that can that can find I never
had that one I'm not gonna eat that it's
just bread soaked in drippings right
it's basically like congealed blood in a
sausage casing there's no carrier
I'm not sure what all is in there I
would think it would be something like
french bread dipped in blood I don't
know put inside the casing
maybe but I don't think so okay I've
also seen it called Black Pudding I
think it's the same thing
they have that with breakfast you got to
be desperate to come up with [__] like
that those the British didn't have
anything that's why they were serving
they still eat it though you know one of
the weirdest things that Cajuns eat that
they shouldn't be eating because they
just have bad habits like you should not
be eating [__] dinner on the half
shell
yeah please just don't need an armadillo
I mean yeah eating Armadillo on there
yeah that's just not like healthy you're
better off eating a maggot plus they're
cute yeah you're better off eating
maggots but they'll eat that yeah
which I don't that can't taste that good
and half a Time's Roadkill
they'll jump out and go that's still
fresh and then put that in the back of
the car hey don't let that go to waste
yeah I don't think they do it anymore I
don't think they do it anymore I mean I
was doing that [__] he's dead now but he
was doing that was that what killed him
no he drank himself to death oh that's
right yeah I didn't realize that was the
same the Drake himself to death on
purpose it's like [__] you got fired and
he said [__] it even though they were
giving him his retirement money
but because he couldn't go to work he's
literally drank until he sent him to the
hospital he says you keep drinking
you're gonna die he goes that's the idea
and they send it back home he kept
drinking and drinking and died drink
himself to death
well he got what he wanted he was sick
of this [__]
I always thought I thought that was so
strange and that seems to be
I think that's the thing like from past
Generations yeah but it definitely does
seem like after like a lot of dudes
retired they just kind of like they just
kind of cacked like after a couple years
because they're they sell their their
whole purpose was gone I'm like holy
crap I could think of like a million
things I could do if I didn't have to
work that's what they identified with
that's what their status was was their
job which I understand that you know
like but can I really identify with
military stuff you know um
but I don't have to do that anymore
you know what I mean [__] that was I
was a kid when I did a lot of that [__]
you know [__] just
I don't know some dudes have to have a a
reason to get up every day
but there's a million things you could
do like there's a million different
Hobbies you could have there's a million
different things you could do like if
you didn't yeah to go to work well I
think some that particular generation of
baby boomers just didn't think that way
I guess not no
but I was just thought that was so
strange
that seemed to happen a lot though like
that particular generation like a lot of
the dudes would retire and then
they were like dead in a couple years
yeah or they were just like sitting
around driving their wives crazy
yeah sticks I don't armadillo would not
be delicious so like
it would probably just taste like rat
every time you talk about armadillos I
just keep I keep thinking about that
story of that one you saw like popping
out of a deer's bottle yeah ran out of
the damn dead deer
I was going around
I was heading to the to the deer Woods
to shoot some of the [__] that I'd
[__] new hand loads I came up with I
was probably shooting 30 car being in 45
1911 45 Auto and probably had some other
[__]
because it wasn't far from my dad's
house only a couple miles
and uh there's a dead deer in the middle
of the road and I was looking at it and
I was going damn is that one of our deer
and it moved it's barely moved and then
[__] armadillo ran out of its [__]
I was like what the [__] and I kept
[__] running and running hey yeah
he's in there eating oh
he was in there eating
I was like damn
things are [__] nasty how funny would
it have been if you'd seen him going in
there oh man
it's like what is that armadillo doing
it may have been a female deer it may
have not been an [__]
see it wasn't rotten they don't really
have teeth so they try to get to where
the softest part was fret it was fresh
so it went inside of its ass to go get
something to eat
yeah and it came out full oh man it was
good
it's like popping over to 7-Eleven
oh the animal yeah they just like don't
even give a [__] at all do they yeah
that was before I went into the army
yeah that's before I went into the
Arby's I must have been about 19
20 maybe I was like what the [__] is
that
yeah I think armadillos are cute but I
wouldn't you know no you don't want to
touch them no I don't want to touch them
they're [__] dirty yeah well like I
said any any animal that you know makes
its living or you know like eats
carrying and stuff like that you
probably don't wanna
I mean they they serve a like a valuable
purpose in the in the ecosystem but you
probably don't want to like hang out
with them or nothing
you know like vultures
uh Jeffy art said when I retire I'd go
back to doing my fine art yeah I kind of
feel like I could think of a million
things because I tell you guys all the
time it's like I got 40 million ideas
for books I want to write and like all
this [__] I want to do and I just don't
have time to do it
you know
so like if I ever get to retire which
I'm sure I won't um you know maybe I'll
get around to doing it then
I just feel I'm probably never gonna get
to retire I don't think
yeah that's fine I got all these gay
fans in there
getting off on the gay stories that I
tell it's [__] funny
it's all right I'm going to give you
I'll give it give you all gay as a
tribute when I start opening up my only
fans
yeah yeah
it's not done yet you know what I mean
but yeah open the one up
we're gonna see well you know it was
easy yeah it was it did you can do it in
like a couple steps and I just put I
just put pictures on her uh you know
just pictures of me and you
I was trying to see if I could do 13
o'clock on it you can't
you can't because you can't use any
apostrophes you can't use any numbers
Senora stick says self-publishing Jenny
yeah I know I've I've actually
self-published a lot of books yeah uh so
far but I have like ideas for a million
more I want to do and retire from what
uh the job that I had to get because I
don't have enough money now like my
graphic design job yeah
wait a minute what
they're talking about
um because you got a job I know that's
what I said oh okay that's what I said
well I have a job and a bunch of gigs
like I do this show I do a bunch of
freelance like I said you know I work
all week I work 40 hours a week plus you
know 10 extra hours of commute because
it's far and um I have I do a bunch of
freelance I have to do I have to make
three posters and I'm gonna talk to Big
Tom I'm gonna try to tell big time I
lose it big time I need [__] like an
extra 200 bucks a week is there anything
you need me to do because I bet you he's
got all kinds of [__] he needed me to do
I could be running that bike night down
there you know
at the club yeah they could be doing
that you could do that because I'm doing
handyman [__] you go down there go down
there on Tuesday night and his mom is
like you need to help him you need to
help him he needs help
so ask him that's what I'm gonna say I
said dude you need your personal
assistant bro
you know what I mean he needs somebody
to keep his ass [__] keeping that
business running right something with
ideas and [__]
he's hanging out with that new girl too
much see
she's not pushing him into the right
business
the right way see because bike night
they were trying to sell hard liquor to
those guys those guys are racing after
all that [__] they can't get loaded yeah
so really there should have been like a
real light alcohol option or a
non-alcoholic option to sell those dudes
food would have would have been better
yeah I kind of feel like well because
and they started doing food like out on
the patio like recently so like they
have a hot dog guy out there now I would
have sold all those and the bike night's
gonna happen whether mannequin
mannequins you it does that or not
because now they're they're in the habit
they'll go to any of those bars now yeah
cause there's a bunch of bars there's a
bunch of them so what I would do is sell
them
cheap food where you know they spend
five bucks but they get a lot to eat
something like something you could get
[__] real uh easy like uh bulk
meatballs or something yeah yeah I mean
something you gotta you just got you got
an audience there you just gotta sell
them something that's all it is and I
mean he was talking about doing food
anyway and like I said on Friday like at
v13 on Friday nights they have the hot
dog guy out on the patio yeah so they
have started doing food they have like a
way of doing it and I would do the food
on the front step of the club they're
not going into the club
they want to stand outside with their
bikes right so you got to put put it out
on the sidewalk yeah set up like a cart
or something right there on a sidewalk
where you're selling stuff to eat or ice
cream or ice cream bar or something like
that something for a dollar
but you see I gave all the information
away that's that's what I would tell Tom
so he needs me down there to do that
figure that kind of [__] out well ask
him about it I'm gonna talk to his mama
see I've got the Insiders I'm gonna get
his mama to [__] do it see once I get
his money because she runs the door yeah
and and [__] [__]
she kind of runs him too
but like I said I gotta I gotta do three
posters for for mannequins actually for
the next three Fridays yeah uh Victor
says I hate my job until that direct
deposit hits every Friday yeah yeah it
is nice having regular money again
Senora stick says big Tom are you medium
Tom I'm I'm probably little Tom
do we know what media do we know a
medium we call each other Tom but I just
call him big Tom yeah but I'll call it
to his face I just call him Tom but to
other people when I'm talking about him
I say big Tom so they know so they know
so they don't think that you're talking
about yourself in the third person yeah
they're like oh my God he's losing his
mind Tom did this and that I just like
uh that's you right we don't actually
know that but I think that's the only
two times we know
now that I'm thinking about it
but yeah that's what we just make joke
about Big Time little time big well
because big Tom is he's actually like uh
quite big he's like he's quite tall
yeah Camp guy said barbecue sandwiches
tamales Tacos yeah you can do all that
[__] because there's um I'm trying to
think like
right across the street there's some
kind of there's another kind of bar or
restauranty type situation but there's
it's downtown Sanford so there's a bunch
of restaurants there's a lot of German
restaurants down there for some reason
I'm not really sure why
the kind of big one down there is called
holler box and they have like a big
restaurant in the front and then they
have one that's like a deli in the back
but then actually that place is really
good and then there's another one
what's that other one called there's
another one too like a couple blocks
away that's just like around the corner
for mannequins but yeah there's all kind
of there's like there's one place called
The West End Trading Company that's like
a
second it's kind of like a sports bar
but they they have like a restaurant and
then it's like a bar and then they have
like bands play there and [__] like that
I've never been there but I used to do
ads for them all the time like when I
worked at print shop in Longwood
but
yeah I kind of feel like yeah Tom's been
thinking about maybe
um
going down there because he's been going
down there for bike night it's not just
there it's everywhere in downtown
Sanford I can just like all the bikers
kind of like Converge on downtown
Sanford and just like hang out and like
go to the different places and whatnot
so he's been going on there on Tuesday
nights to
do that and you know he's like maybe I
could like pick up some extra money down
there
I didn't know about the only fans he
only just that Sophie about that he
keeps like joking about it but I'm just
like oh I guess he's serious
oh [__] I was what have I got myself
into
but yeah um senior six yeah in case you
didn't know like starting back in
February I actually had to go back and
get that's why we're not doing as many
like recorded shows and movie reviews
and stuff like that because I went back
and got um like a regular
nine to five Joe bullets eight five
actually and uh
regular graphic design job and it's in
um South Daytona which is about
an hour from here
so I have to leave
here about 6 30 in the morning in order
to get there on time
and then I'll get home until like a
little past six
it is after nine yeah some stuff that I
gotta do I want to shave and [__]
brush my teeth and [__] like that okay
get ready so yeah I mean I'm mostly
ready I just got to put my shoes on and
get my phone and all that kind of [__]
together all right then shut it down
okay
so uh oh my God the neighbors are yeah
they're coming behind it down they well
they get excited when it's Friday
they're always like blaring the music
out the windows and [__] like that
because I'm just like okay I know you're
excited but
uh Camp guy recommended tamales said you
can make a ton of tamales at home and
then take them hot to a street vending
cart like sell them in the front that
might work
yes yeah I mean wax paper that's that's
pretty labor intensive okay I mean
tamale would cost a lot to do in the
United States because uh that's hours
and hours of work I'd want a lot of
money for them when I got done with them
if I could buy them pre-made for a
decent price so maybe I would but then
your overheads would kill you be better
to do something like
go down there
and buy a bunch of ice cream bars and
sell them for a dollar
or something something yeah they're 25
cents a piece you make 75 cents on each
one of them or and then you have some
ice cream bars and then you have some
[__] sandwiches
something that's really easy to eat
street food that you can walk around did
you walk around and walk over there and
sell it to them right yeah you can make
like some of those like walk-in tacos
like the [__] they make in a Frito bag
yeah
you know what I mean you could do that
uh all right so yeah I guess we're gonna
wrap it up for this Friday night because
we're gonna go out so hopefully you guys
have a good afternoon and a good Easter
we will probably be on uh doing a movie
review Sunday well hi Pokey yeah did you
see your little head pop yeah he popped
up and she's like hello yeah but um
if Fargo comes tomorrow it's supposed to
come tomorrow he said okay then we'll
watch that tomorrow night and we'll
review that on Sunday or if not then
we'll do the Breakfast Club yeah how
about that so it'll be one of those two
movies
um and then if whichever one we didn't
get to we'll get to the other one either
Tuesday or next week uh so yeah and then
like I said Wednesday we I don't know
what the show's gonna be yet because the
poll is still up so if you're a YouTube
member or a or if you're on our patreon
then you can go and vote on I don't
remember what the choices were that I
put up this week but yeah so you can go
vote for what the show's gonna be on
Wednesday so uh yeah have a good night
you guys and have a good day tomorrow
and we will see you guys again on Sunday
good night